almost always by the time the image gets
to a monitor it'll be an RGB format
because that's the format that the
monitors use so color spaces are a way
of representing the colors in an image
in a different way and a lot of
high-definition video uses ycbcr on the
other hand by the time the colors get to
a printer it'll be in CMYK format
because that's an format that printers
understand and that's a color of their
inks RGB stands for red green and blue
and apart from being the format we've
talked about in velocity videos it's
also a format used by monitors so if you
want to show something on the screen
it's been basically put into RGB format
that's how much red have we got how much
blue have we got and how much green have
we got when you add a colors together
you get different colors and indeed when
you add all the colors together you get
white if you take away all the colors
you get black that's different to let's
say the way the printers work where if
you add all the colors together you get
black because if you keep adding colors
in with your inks you eventually get
black so if we draw a little RGB diagram
here so if this is red and this is green
and this is blue and halfway between
blue and red will be magenta between
blue and green is cyan and between red
and green is yellow and then between all
three is white and then outside of these
you've obviously got black so you can
create any color you like on your
monitor by varying the different amounts
of these three colors so on printers it
works slightly differently so see em Y
and then K is black but we don't tend to
have K as part of this color we'll use
it to just create black effects because
it works better halfway between C and M
is blue and then halfway between C and y
we've got green and then between magenta
and yellow we've got red and in the
middle of all of them unlike RGB we've
got black here so we're going to put K
for black because we've already got blue
so this works in a completely different
way to RGB so it's additive so the more
dyes we add the darker everything gets
and then we use cade actually just print
in black if we want to so even though
there's not separate round circle there
on your diagram for K you would have a
fourth yeah because in practice what you
might find is that if you try and add my
and C together
get black in principle it works but
you'll end up with a kind of muddy dark
brown ink which is just not as good as
just printing in black and you're
wasting a lot of toner doing that so so
just print in black the last color spray
screen look at is ycbcr variants of it
commonly used in TV broadcasting so for
example pal
users users at color space NTS they use
in a similar color space but slightly
different and a lot of high-definition
video uses ycbcr what we're trying to do
with ycbcr is separate the luminosity of
an image so the intensity of each pixel
from the actual color and by doing that
we can do all kinds of clever things by
downsampling the color and things that
we'll get onto when we talked a little
bit about shaping this is a picture I
took of a flower okay
and this is currently in RGB form and if
we want to split this into ycbcr what we
need to do is take away the grayscale
and and the color and separate them this
is just the luminosity component so this
is just Y and that essentially is a
grayscale version of the image how
bright is each pixel and then we've also
got the CB and the CR components so CB
represents the kind of the chrominance
the blueness of an image so in this case
some of the flower in the middle is blue
and the background is kind of blue but
the actual flower is quite yellow and
then the CR is the redness chrominance
value so how red is it and you can see
it's actually pretty red and the
background is not very very tall so you
mentioned your own sort of blue but
we're seeing obviously grey and yellow
what I've done here is I've set the
luminosity over the image to be flat at
0 and by doing that the image isn't
bright and isn't dark and we're just
only seeing both Phoebe and CR so let me
do a little bit of writing it down so
you can see it better okay where we
would normally have RGB instead we have
y cbcr
so this is written this way there's lots
of variations on how you write this so
we usually use this prime symbol after
the Y to represent that the RGB was
gamma corrected but we won't worry too
much about that for all intents and
purposes this is the luminosity and
these are the chrominance values and
this luminosity goes between nought and
just like RGB and the CB and CR are
positions on a sort of a square and they
go from minus 1 to 7 to 120
eight it might be - hundred twenty-eight
to one to seven okay so that's for CB
and CR and so what we essentially have
is a cube like this where ry goes in
this direction and this is black down
here and this is white and then our CB
and CR are in these directions so this
will be CR and this will be CB and light
in the centre where both of these values
are zero is gray and our grayscale line
is right down the center of this cube
and then arc this direction will get
more and more red and then less and less
red down in this direction and up in
this direction will get more and more
blue and down will go less and less blue
okay that's clearly more yellow in this
case yes although we call it blue miss
actually also in this direction the less
blue it is in a sense the more yellow it
is but similarly we've read the less red
it is in general the more green it is
but these colors only start to look
realistic once you're putting them both
back together again and then combine
them with the luminosity component so
we've seen three different colors basses
and sort of roughly haven't worked well
use one of them so in general if you had
a choice you would use RGB because it's
widely supported it's what ends up
needing to be output to a computer
monitor so graphics cars talking RGB
most of the time if you're going to
print anything you're going to have to
produce it in to turn it into CMYK most
of the print drivers will do this for
you so you don't need to worry about
that if you go into Windows or any other
operating system and you print an RGB
image it will convert it to CMYK for you
and that will tell the printer how much
ink it needs to use of the different
colors you would generally use ycbcr if
you're doing any kind of TV broadcasting
so if you're actually sending a stream
of data to someone's television you need
to worry about how much compression you
have on that data because it's quite
important and ycbcr lets you do very
clever techniques by downsampling the
color components but not down sampling
the luminance component and people won't
really notice and we'll talk about about
that when we talk about JPEG and tape it
I thought I should say it's as
fundamental to how JPEG works is down
sampling of the color components
we'd like to thank harrys.com for
sponsoring this computer file video
they're a subscription shaving service
so if you go to harrys.com check out
some of the products they'll deliver
them right to your door I've been using
Harris products for a while now they've
recently sent me this chrome razor which
is really really cool all the products
are really really nicely packaged and
I've also been using the foaming shave
gel on this aftershave lotion and if
you've got skin that's not so good like
mine you'll find these make a really
really nice job of it so check out
Harry's com the subscriptions shaving
service if you use the coupon code
computerphile you'll get five dollars
off so thanks once again to Harry's for
sponsoring this computerphile video so
JPEG works by down stopping the car
components and using other techniques as
well the majority of video compression
methods will do the same thing so you're
being compressed right now I certainly
am yes